dieser pure 3500
schiff in bewegung
pipelines verlegen wir arbeiten hier
rund um die uhr
leisten heben sein schlachtung der kahn
ist im einsatz
eine förderplattform in rekordzeit
aufstellen
[Musik]
es geht um millimeter mitten im ozean
wir wissen dass hier ein stürzen können
fehler sind unverzeihlich
jetzt gibt es kein zurück mehr
holliger und kranschiff in einem dieser
purer 3500 ist ein multitalent
sie verlegt pipelines am meeresboden
unterlassen
ihr kran hebt bis zu 3500 tonnen schwere
lasten
und sie hat anna rovi an bord ein
ferngesteuertes unterwasserfahrzeug
michael murphy ist kapitän der sakura
3500 seit ihrem ersten tag auf see
dieses schiff ist das schweizer
taschenmesser der hochsee
es gibt pfiffe die eins oder zwei dieser
dinge können aber kein schiff kann alles
zusammen es ist ein wahnsinn chef
die sakura
3500 ist über 156 meter lang und knapp
45 meter breit für diesen einsatz muss
sie ins südchinesische meer 200
kilometer vor der nordostküste malaysias
hier gibt es ein großes erdöl und erdgas
fällt
das rohr einen meter nach vorn
die besatzung hat tagelang rohrstücke
von einem frachtkahn ausgeladen und
zusammengeschweißt
die jetzt knapp 9 km eine pipeline wird
über das heck des schiffs auf dem
meeresgrund gelassen
doch das ist erst der anfang danach wird
eine 1700 tonnen schwere förderplattform
zusammengebaut und errichtet
[Musik]
mit hilfe des krans wird das sogenannte
jacking eine vierbeinige
tragekonstruktion ins meer gelassen und
am meeresgrund befestigt
danach wird das topmodell der
bohrplattform auf dem jacket befestigt
sobald die bohrplattform steht kann
erdgas gefördert und durch die neu
verlegte pipeline nach malaysia und
vietnam transportiert werden
bei dieser arbeit ist ihm leute fragt
jeder muss seinen teil beitragen
[Musik]
es ist fast mitternacht gearbeitet wird
rund um die uhr
die 150 mann starke crew wechselt sich
in zwölf stunden schichten ab sie liegen
gut in der zeit
wir stehen unter druck weil alles
rechtzeitig fertig werden muss
[Musik]
eine
technischer oberaufseher mohammed osman
aziz an muss sicherstellen dass alles
nach plan läuft
der schweissen pro tag 200 stücke
zusammen es läuft gut
die pipeline besteht aus mehr als 700
zwölf meter langen beton ummantelten
rohrstücke jedes rohrstück durchläuft in
einer stunde zehn arbeitsstationen
[Musik]
an der ersten station geht es los die
rohre werden verschweißt die
schweißnähte mit hochspannungs geräten
geprüft und dann beschichtet danach wird
die pipeline ins meer gelassen
an manchen stationen werden die rohre
maschinell verschweißt die schweiz
automaten arbeiten zehn mal schneller
als ein mensch bei gleicher qualität
[Musik]
wurden zwei rohrstücke verschweißt
fed-chef zwölf meter weiter so kommt
automatisch das nächste rohrstück
die schweißnähte werden beschichtet und
so wasserdicht gemacht
die schweißnähte zwischen den einzelnen
rohr stecken dürfen keine fehler haben
ein leck in der pipeline wäre ein
ökologisches und finanzielles desaster
darum wird jede schweißnaht geröntgt
und überprüft
ist eine naht fehlerhaft wird sie noch
mal das schweißen
das kostet uns aber wertvolle zeit
erst wenn die verbindung überprüft ist
wird das rohr ins wasser gelassen
[Musik]
diese stützkonstruktion am heck des
schiffs heistinger
sie stabilisiert die pipeline wären sie
ins wasser gelassen wird die pipeline
muss langsam und gleichmäßig auf den
meeresboden sinken sie rutscht
automatisch ins wasser wenn sich das
schiff stück für stück zwölf meter
vorwärts bewegt
[Musik]
sobald die rohrstücke verschweißt sind
werden sie nicht mehr bewegt es ist das
schiff das sich bewegt so wird die
pipeline ins wasser gelassen sie bleibt
wo sie ist
das schiff bewegt sich vorwärts mit
weniger als einem kilometer pro stunde
vermessungs teams haben im voraus
berechnet wo die pipeline verlegt werden
soll das schiff darf nicht vom kurs
abweichen sonst erreicht die pipeline
nicht die neue förderplattform
[Musik]
die brücke
wir setzen uns in bewegung auf der
brücke steuert offizieren tom carroll
das schiff die 8,8 km lange pipeline
wird genau nach plan verlegt
die acht strahle ruder an der unterseite
des schiffes korrigieren den kurs
automatisch je nach wellengang oder
meeresströmungen
[Musik]
sie halten die sakura 3500 auf position
mit einer maximalen abweichung von nur
zehn zentimetern
[Musik]
alle stationen chef in bewegung
es darf keine ruckartigen bewegungen
geben je gleichmäßiger sich das schiff
bewegt desto weniger kräfte waren
wenn man im auto stark bremst gibt es
einen ruck bei einem schiff ist das
genauso wenn starke kräfte wirken wird
das schiff im stabil
die pipeline kommt wie eine spaghetti
aus dem schiffsweg rutscht ins wasser
und landet
das sieht aus wie eingestaubt des looks
like eines chors
sowie fred richtung sting
die pipeline darf sich nicht zu stark
durch biegen die crew überwacht den
vorgang mit hilfe der aufnahmen des
tauchroboters
es darf keine schäden an beschichtung
oder schweißnaht umhüllung geben das ist
wichtig
[Musik]
15 metern
6 uhr morgens die pipeline ist fast
fertig
jetzt muss sie nur noch verschlossen
werden
wir machen den ableger kopf drauf
danach rollt sie über den sticker auf
den meeresboden
der ableger kopf verhindert dass wasser
in die pipeline bringt bevor sie an die
plattform angeschlossen wird
ladegut halten
der kapitän lotst die sakura 3500 ins
zielgebiet
nach sechs tagen ist es endlich soweit
ein tolles gefühl
die 8,8 kilometer lange pipeline sinkt
auf den meeresgrund ohne lecks oder
risse
bald wird sie eine eine gas
förderplattform angeschlossen
das ist die nächste große
herausforderung die neue plattform zu
errichten mitten im ozean und ohne
fremde hilfe wir können uns keine fehler
leisten es muss auf anhieb sitzen
die sakura 3500 hat sieben tage lang
eine unterwasser pipeline verlegt jetzt
kommt der nächste schritt bei diesem
großprojekt vor der malaysischen küste
eine 1700 tonnen schwere förderplattform
aufstellen die besteht aus zwei teilen
das tragende stahlgerüst nennt man
jacket darauf wird das so genannte top
sites modul gesetzt
dazu muss die crew das schiff umbauen
von rohleder zum kranschiff
als erstes muss das ding über den die
pipeline ins wasser gelassen wurde aus
dem weg
die vier großen bolzen die den
stillhalten werden entfernt
ja alle
der stinger wiegt 670 tonnen kein
problem für den kran der sakura mit
einer traglast von
3500 tonnen
doch die 65 meter lange
stützkonstruktion ist sperrig
wir brauchen mehr holzblöcke hier unten
[Musik]
jeder weiß genau was er zu tun
alle kennen die abläufe wenn etwas nicht
nach plan läuft kann jeder hier an bord
stopp rufen
dann wird alles angehalten
doch ein stück
selbst unter idealen bedingungen dauert
es eine stunde den singer vom heck des
schiffs sicher auf dem frachtkahn zu
verleihen ohne den sting wird aus dem
rohr läge ein kranschiff bereit für die
nächste aufgabe die arbeit beginnt in
den frühen morgenstunden
[Musik]
5 uhr
noch etwas weiter
ein weiterer frachtkahn liefert das top
sites montilla bohrinsel und das steiger
ist auch dass es montiert wird das
sogenannte jacking
doch der kann hat probleme längsseits
anzulegen
die starke strömung treibt den
frachtkahn vom schiff weg
etwas mehr steuerbar
vom heck der sakura
3500 ausweist kapitän mohammed pfizer
herum seine crew an den frachtkahn zu
verteilen
noch etwa zwei meter
verstanden über 10.000 werden benötigt
um den fracht kam langsam längsseits zu
ziehen
nun hat alles im griff
fast alle tower sind festgemacht nur
noch ein paar dann ist der fracht kann
gesichert hat
[Musik]
doch dann gibt es ein problem
der wind frischt auf
wir müssen uns mit dem verträumte 1
nein ja nicht so
[Musik]
die crew schafft es dem frachtkahn
rechtzeitig zu sichern
wir haben den frachtkahn längsseits
festgemacht
jetzt kann es weitergehen
die crew hat alles für den nächsten
arbeitsschritt vorbereitet das 830
tonnen schwere jackett muss vom
frachtkahn gehoben und an seinen
bestimmungsort am meeresboden gesetzt
werden
der ablauf ist komplex jeder schritt ist
genau auf den nächsten abgestimmt
das jacket wird angehoben
es wird gedreht
und aufgestellt dann wird es backbord
ins wasser gelassen
wenn alles nach plan läuft wird die
operation etwa zwölf stunden dauern
eine sache hat für die crew höchste
priorität auf
dem schiff bereitet ein team von 60
gerüstbauern das anheben des jackets vor
viele arbeiter kommen aus sarawak in ost
malaysia
dort gibt es die weltbesten gerüstbauer
sie müssen sicherstellen dass diese
stahlkonstruktion beim anheben nicht ins
schwanken gerät
so stellen wir sicher dass ist nicht
unkontrolliert hin und her schwingt
sobald der kahn bereit ist wird es
angehoben
gleichzeig die sakura
3500 was in ihr steckt
der kran kann dreieinhalb tausend tonnen
heben das entspricht einem gewicht von
700 elefanten
1 700 elefanten gehoben werden müssen
sind wir zur stelle
auf dem weg sind alle augen auf das
jacket gerichtet
achtung schwergut wird gehoben
gleich wird das jacket angeboten das
schiff ist bereits um anheben
stückweise 200 tonnen stückweise 200
tonnen mit dem hauptgang
langsam anheben
verstanden
wir heben das jacket schrittweise an
anstatt es mit einem mal hochzuheben
hebt es da kann langsam fragt wärt pro
schritt 200
wir müssen den fracht kam mit
fingerspitzengefühl entladen unser chef
darf nicht in bewegung gehabt wenn wir
die last verlagern
strahl ruder unter wasser verhindern
dass sich das schiff mehr als zehn
zentimeter bewegt
[Musik]
nochmal 200
die nächsten 200 hauptgrund
jeder an bord überprüft alle vorgänge
ein 23 mal
jetzt trägt er kran das volle gewicht
des jackets
830 tonnen
wenn das jacket komplett in der luft
wird es brenzlig
denn das ganze gewicht das auf dem
frachtkahn bar hängt jetzt am k
830 tonnen stahl schweben über dem meer
das ist erst der anfang der riskanten
montage
jetzt gibt es kein zurück mehr
[Musik]
dieser purer
3500 liegt im südchinesischen meer sie
errichtet vor der walisischen küste eine
förderplattform
das tragende stahlgerüst der plattform
das sogenannte jacking hängt der länge
nach am schiffs krank es muss hochkant
gestellt werden bevor es auf dem
meeresgrund abgesetzt werden kann
[Musik]
gleich lassen wir das jacket ins wasser
mit diesen zwei kabeln wird es gedreht
eins davon zieht eins davon bremst
[Musik]
um das jacket aufzustellen muss der
kranführer ist zuerst unter wasser
lassen
wenn ein objekt ins wasser getaucht wird
verdrängt dass sein eigengewichts an
wasser im wasser ist es also leichter
und weil das wasser auch alle bewegungen
dämpft ist das jacket unter wasser
leichter zu handhaben
das jacket mit dem wasser gedreht bis
ist die verlängerung vom heck bildet
das kabel auf der hilfs wände einziehen
während der schwerlastkran das jacket
dreht wird der tauchroboter zu wasser
gelassen
[Musik]
er begleitet das stahlgerüst in die
tiefe
der tauchroboter zeigt an wie weit es
noch zum meeresgrund ist
im moment sind es etwa 33 meter
der tauchroboter hat auch ein auge
darauf dass sich beim aufrichten keine
kabel verheddern
es ist wichtig ist das jacket erstmal im
wasser sehen wir nichts mehr
der kranführer kippt das jacket bis die
gerüst beine zum meeresboden zeigen
[Musik]
die hortkinder ablassen
doch woanders
das jacket ist jetzt aufgerichtet etwa
zehn meter über den meeresgrund
die crew hat dieses schwierige manöver
perfekt ausgeführt
[Musik]
es ist nicht leicht einen job auf der
sakura 3500 zu bekommen nur experten mit
viel erfahrung in der industrie schaffen
es auf dieses schiff
solange das jacket noch am kran hängt
muss die crew hochkonzentriert sein
schränkt
das jacket backbord wird das hauptkabel
gelöst danach wird es ins wasser
herunter gelassen auf seine endgültige
position
während der kran das jacket schwenkt
sind die gerüst beine noch zehn meter
über dem meeresboden
die zeit läuft die arbeit ist erst
vorbei wenn der stahlgerüst auf dem
meeresboden steht
[Musik]
in 50 metern erreichen wir die
endposition
auf der brücke steuert kapitän michael
murphy das schiff an die richtige stelle
wir mussten noch zehn meter fahren um
zur vorgegebenen position zu kommen
jetzt sind wir am ziel angekommen
die strömung ist stark acht strahlrohr
halten das schiff in position während
das stahl fundament abgesenkt wird wie
viele meter zum boden
langsam setzt der kran das jacket auf
den meeresboden ab in 60 meter tiefe mit
hilfe des tauchroboters
verfolgt die crew den vorgang
[Musik]
der tauchroboter umkreist das jacket
so sehen wir ob es richtig positioniert
ist
[Musik]
jaquet noch fünf meter nach unten
der ort auf dem das jacket stehen soll
ist knapp bemessen
[Musik]
wir können fünf meter abweichen aber wir
peilen einen meter an
kurz vor mitternacht erreicht es sein
ziel
wir haben das jacket erfolgreich auf der
vorgegebenen position abgesetzt
[Musik]
die arbeit ist noch nicht vorbei jetzt
muss das jacket verankert werden dieser
arbeitsschritt erfordert besonderes
fingerspitzengefühl
es ist nicht ungefährlich das jacket
kann und kippen solange es nicht am
meeresboden befestigt ist
das bauprojekt vor der küste von
malaysia geht in die zweite woche die
crew der sakura
3500 muss das stahlgerüst einer gas
förderplattform am meeresboden
befestigen bevor es um kind
hängt noch am kranhaken
diese situation ist heikel denn das
jacket wird nur noch von cannes gehalten
wir müssen aufpassen dass das gerüst
nicht gibt oder im sand am meeresboden
stecken bleibt
und das jacket im meeresboden zu
verankern kommen stahlrohre in seiner
holen gerüst beine in jedes der vier
beine kommen insgesamt vier rohre die
miteinander verschweißt werden diese
rohre werden dann hat sich meter tief in
den meeresboden eingetreten
[Musik]
bevor das erste stahlrohr
heruntergelassen wird bauen die arbeiter
ein gerüst um die vierbeiner des
checkers auf diesen plattformen werden
die rohre zusammengeschweißt
die schweizer und der rest der crew
arbeiten auf dem offenen meer das sind
extreme bedingungen
es ist nicht einfach sehr zeit und
arbeitsaufwendig diesen job fehlerfrei
und sicher zu erledigen
es dauert zwei tage
alle vier gerüst beine zu befestigen wir
setzen das erste rohr 1
das jacket in über zwölf stunden lange
mehr seit gestern abend steht es auf dem
meeresboden jetzt muss es schnell
befestigt werden
der schiffs kran hebt das zweite rohr
auf das erste
[Musik]
die arbeiter verschweißen die beiden
endstücke
ich prüfe die schweißnaht
wir prüfen sie doppelt und dreifach
wenn das rohr erstmal im wasser ist
können wir es nicht mehr prüfen
das ist fertig
das stahlrohr ist so schwer dass es in
das feinkörnige sediment des
meeresbodens sinkt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sie sahen behält die tiefen markierungen
des chors im auge
normalerweise bleibt das rohr nach etwa
17 metern stecken
dann stößt es auf eine härtere
sedimentschicht doch heute läuft es
nicht wie geplant
[Musik]
wenn es weiter sinkt brauchen wir den
stopp
eigentlich sollte das rohr stecken
bleiben aber es singt weiter
der meeresboden scheint hier sehr weich
zu sein wir können nur hoffen dass das
arbeit stecken bleibt
susan weiß nicht warum das rohr immer
weiter sinkt der standort wurde im
voraus geprüft
[Musik]
wir können das rohe 19 20 meter runter
lassen aber wenn es tiefer sinkt können
wir es verlieren
nur der kran verhindert dass das rohr
noch tiefer sinkt wenn er aus klingt
könnte das ruhe so lange weiter sinken
bis es aus dem gerüst band rutscht diese
situation nennt man paul bonn
das darf auf keinen fall passieren
[Musik]
wenn das rohr durchrutscht können wir
keine weiteren rohre nachschieben das
bedeutet das aus für die förderplattform
susan muss handeln sein team schweißt
metallklammern an den frei liegenden
teil des ohres jetzt kann es nicht mehr
durch
[Musik]
wir haben entschieden stopper an das ohr
zu schweißen auf diese weise können wir
es nicht mehr verlieren
das rohr im ersten gerüst beinen ist
gesichert jetzt werden die rohre im
zweiten gerüst sein zusammengeschweißt
dadurch wird das jackett stabilisiert
[Musik]
das jacket steht sicherer wenn wir die
nächsten rohre im zweiten gerüst ein
unterlassen
[Musik]
zwölf stunden später
mittlerweile wurden zwei rohre in den
meeresboden gelassen was für eine
erleichterung
jetzt sind zwei rohre in den tourist
beinen dadurch ist das jacket relativ
gut gesichert
die gute nachricht das jacket ist
stabilisiert die schlechte nachricht
sie sahen weiß nicht ob er es am
meeresboden auch sicher verankern kann
[Musik]
vorerst wird weiter gearbeitet
die nächsten rohre kommen in das dritte
und vierte gerüstbau
die rohre kommen nacheinander ein
[Musik]
das jacket muss möglichst eben stehen
wenn es sich in eine richtung neigt wird
es mit hilfe der rohre in den beinen
wieder ausgerichtet
es muss waagerecht seien
alle vier rohre sind in die obere
sedimentschicht des meeres bonus
eingesunken jetzt wird der hydraulik
kamera eingesetzt
das team von offshore bauleiter langman
befestigt den hydraulikhammer am schiffs
krank
anfangs arbeitet er nur mit halber kraft
[Musik]
das erste rohr wissen wer ganz
vorsichtig einrahmen
wir wissen ja nicht wie gut oder wie
schlecht sich das ohr in den meeresboden
schlagen lässt
das sentiment am meeresboden bleibt ein
unsicherheitsfaktor ist es zu locker um
das geld sicher zu verankern muss das
ganze projekt abgebrochen werden
die stimmung an bord der sakura
3500 ist angespannt
[Musik]
der hydraulikhammer des schiffes ist
einsatzbereit
er schlägt die rohre durch die gerüst
beine des jackets in den schlammigen
meeresboden doch der bauleiter hat
bedenken die sedimentschicht am
meeresboden könnte zu locker sein der
hammer arbeitet erstmal mit halber kraft
wir beginnen mit kurzen schläge ein
wir setzen minimale kraft ein
höchstens ein schlag
der hammer bewegt sich von einem ohr zum
anderen so bleibt das jackett die ganze
zeit über in der waagerechten
die crew muss aufpassen dass kannst der
rohre durch gerüst bahn rutscht
es ist wichtig dass das jacket 100
prozent stabil im meeresboden verankert
ist
schließlich ist es das fundament für das
top sites module
am nächsten morgen sind alle rohre in
den meeresboden geschlagen doch stehen
sie auch wirklich sicher
am anfang war der meeresboden weich je
tiefer die rohre rampe umso fester wurde
er
doch das jacket steht noch nicht sicher
das könnte den zeitplan
durcheinanderbringen
vielleicht müssen wir tiefer gehen das
wäre schlecht
sein muss überprüfen ob das stahlgerüst
auch wirklich sicher im meeresboden
verankert ist nur dann kann das
topmodell auf das jacket gesetzt werden
[Musik]
wenn der meeresboden zu weich ist könnte
das gerüst mit dem top sites motto
singen
[Musik]
mit den sensoren an den rohren können
wir prüfen ob die plattform sicher auf
dem meeresboden steht
[Musik]
wenn der hydraulik haben wir ein rohr in
den boden rammt vibriert ist anhand der
vibrationen misst der sensor wie fest
dass rohre im boden steckt je stärker
das rohr vibriert desto fester ist es
verankert das ergebnis des tests ist
entscheidend
[Musik]
ist der boden zu weich können wir das
top zeit module nicht aufsetzen
im schlimmsten fall müssten die rohre
tiefer in den meeresboden gerammt werden
bis sie in festem gesteinsschichten
stehen dazu bräuchte die crew aber
weitere rohre es werde tage dauern bis
sie geliefert werden
die sensoren liefern erste taten
[Musik]
die kraft mit der der hammer schlägt
wird in mega newton angegeben
hier sieht man weich
sie sahen hofft dass das gerät 20
minuten anzeigt doch es hat weniger
gemessen statt 20 sind es nur 15 minuten
das ist ein problem der boden ist
weicher als wir erwartet hatten
sie sahen kann momentan keine endgültige
entscheidung treffen
meeresboden um das rohr sagt noch nach
vielleicht festigt er sich mit der zeit
wir messen in 24 stunden noch mal nach
das sediment um das rohr soll sich erst
setzen
vielleicht lagert sich noch sediment um
das ohr ab
wenn die neue messung nicht höher
ausfällt steht das projekt vor dem aus
neuer tag neue chance sie sahen misst
noch einmal die vibrationen der rohre
der moment der wahrheit die sensoren
zeigen an dass die rohre jetzt fest im
meeresboden verankert sind
es sind 21 5 minuten wir können das
topzeit modul aufsetzen
die arbeit kann weitergehen alle vier
rohre stecken 90 meter tief im
meeresboden das ticket ist sicher
verankert
jetzt muss nur noch das top modell auf
das stahlgerüst gehoben werden es ist
das schwerste teil der förderplattform
[Musik]
wir müssen bis zum ende hoch
konzentriert bleiben in der letzten
phase kann es probleme geben die wollen
wir auf jeden fall vermeiden
[Musik]
auf den schiffs kran der sakura 3500
wartet ein schweres stück arbeit
das nicht sehen nicht sehen die crew
wird gleich das 880 tonnen schwere
topzeit module auf das jacket sitzen
es ist etwa so groß wie ein
zweistöckiges haus
das südchinesische meer ruhig doch sie
sahen steht eine lange nacht bevor
es ist wie bei einer fußball wm man
kämpft sich erst ins viertelfinale ins
halbfinale
und heute ist das endspiel
alle vergaben gleich kommt der schwergut
kran wieder zum einsatz
offshore bauleiter lei yang min erklärt
dem team worauf es bei diesem letzten
ladevorgang zu achten hat
alle müssen konzentriert sein und jeden
arbeitsschritt genauestens kennen
sicherheit sicherheit
jetzt ist es endlich soweit
während des ladevorgangs kommunizieren
alle teams miteinander
im crm
und auf der brücke
wir sind auf position
2 100 tonnen
wir haben 200 tonnen
das modul wird langsam angehoben bis 880
tonnen am kran hängen
ladung gelöscht
wir warten noch bis der chef sich
stabilisiert hat dann schwenkten sie das
modul von steuerbord nach backbord in
richtung jacket
[Musik]
auf der brücke hält kapitän das schiff
an ort und stelle
in der mitte bewegt sich das schiff
maximal 10 cm am heck bewegte sich kaum
bei diesem vorgang ist kommunikation das
ein und alles
[Musik]
von deck aus lotst minden kranführer
wir nähern uns dem tor geht
[Musik]
fast geschafft
der kranführer muss die vier beine des
moduls auf die vier rohre des jackets
setzen
[Musik]
es geht um millimeter
das schiff muss noch ein kleines
stückchen vorwärts fahren
brücke noch einen meter voraus
[Musik]
gleich haben erste künstler
es setzt auf dem jacket
doch es ist noch nicht geschafft
am kran hängen immer noch 600 tonnen
gewicht muss langsam vom kran auf das
jacket übertragen werden
[Musik]
brücke gewicht halten alles top
nach zwei stunden gut das topmodell
vollständig auf dem 6
was für eine tolle leistung von schiff
und crew
das ist unser mann
ich bin stolz auf unsere mannschaft
[Musik]
es ist vom haken jetzt wird das
verschweißt es steht sicher
[Musik]
280 besatzungsmitglieder haben diese
förderplattform mit aufgebaut
sie wird in zukunft millionen von
kubikmetern erdgas fördern das über
pipelines nach malaysia und vietnam
geliefert wird
[Musik]
das schiff ist noch jung hat aber schon
einen guten ruf
auf uns warten viele neue projekte
eine gute crew und ein tolles
die sakura
3500 ist ein multitalent
kollege
kranschiff und tauchboot basis
nachdem jobs vor dem job die nächste
herausforderung wartet schon
[Musik]